à propos d'un monde fou fou fou on peut
dire que poiret serrault maintenant sont
dans un monde folle folle folle appel
je ne comprends pas ce genre d'allusion
vraiment aux nomades
d'ailleurs moi j'ai décidé de ne plus
répondre vraiment c'est pas c'est pas
parce que subitement jour où jouent les
personnages
qui sont des personnages de théâtre qui
sont un personnage de comics à peu près
6 quand la ville on conserve le même
style oui ma face et vous j'en parlais
que décrit cette cage aux folles
vous vous êtes je crois un petit peu en
ménage avec ce que je vous demande si
vous êtes en ménage avec jean-paul alors
que vous faites passer pour votre frère
depuis des années c'est peut-être bien
votre mari alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise
et oui alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette cage aux folles mais qu'est ce qui
se dit il la vérité
la cage aux folles car la location en ce
moment dieu merci ce qu'on en profite un
peu remarqué que je suis pas si passeur
il se passe rien ce sont les messieurs
les messieurs qui se mettent en dames
quoi ça arrive partout ça arrive tout le
temps un mais c'est un vieux couple
pourtant vieux moi tu sais pas ce que
j'ai fait moi je partirai connaissez
leur hétérogénéité
je suis bien incapable de lui lancer un
petit micro à la thèse que oui au
judaïsme il est du coup plus si on coupe
un vieux couple on peut pas jouer de
toute manière
à des protagonistes un vieux couple
enfin n'exagérons pas encore battu ses
voyages et bien avec le maquillage c'est
un coût plus d'un coup une hormone
simplement simplement que sont des gens
qui vivent ensemble depuis depuis une
vingtaine d'années mais ils se font des
métiers travesti mais alors pour la
seule différence c'est que au lieu au
lieu d'avoir un monsieur une dame comme
ça se passe de généralement dans les
couples tels qu'on les a envisagé
jusqu'à présent cela c'est un monsieur à
monsieur c'est la seule différence il
s'ensuit toute une série de
travestissement que je ne vous dirai pas
ici parce qu'ils n'avaient qu'à acheter
vos places roland alors c'est de là
qu'il tient un commerce au palais royal
ont alors dit je dois en commandant les
royals au palais royal